obviously there's a there's a different
look to this city you know it's very
green trees everywhere and uh utah is
definitely not like that um you know
there's definitely some aggressive
drivers here that's for sure
getting used to that you know getting
cut off about every everywhere you go
yeah zack wilson wait till you're out
there with chris sims
chris sims where's the middle finger
from chris sims
uh yeah chris will let chris will let
you have it that is definitely not
chris's tesla and i have a feeling zach
wilson can afford a vehicle slightly
nicer than that modified volkswagen
beetle uh all right
now
we have had uh plenty of quarterbacks
who
have decided that they want to follow in
the footsteps of tom brady make a power
play get out of town control your fate
be involved in crafting the offense and
developing the roster so we know the
guys who currently want out we're gonna
go next level here and this is all
speculation this is all guesswork this
isn't reporting don't freak out fans of
the teams
who have these quarterbacks who may
eventually want to play for a different
team peter i'll give you the first pick
the quarterbacks who may be in the next
wave of guys who make power plays
you know look we're not going to put uh
desean watson in here because obviously
he's
whenever his legal situation is
clarified he's almost certainly going to
be gone um i will i'll just
take a stab uh and look in las vegas
and and i'll say derek carr
and the reason i'll say that is that at
some point
if they keep losing and he keeps hearing
you know the the rumors and the
footsteps behind him that maybe gruden
isn't all in on you he's going to say
i want to go to a place that is behind
me that backs me let me go to carolina
where they're gonna love me
and so i'm gonna start now i'll pick
derek carr to start my little uh
festivities here mike
yeah he was on my list and you get to a
point where you've had enough you feel
like you've been consistently
disrespected you develop some leverage
as you get later into your contract and
maybe you decide i want to be traded
there's nothing preventing a guy from
asking to be traded and or making it
public and more and more guys are going
to do it i'm going to
and
i know that there are fans of a certain
team whose helmet looks like
somebody got drunk and tried to carve up
a pumpkin
but keep it's it's not happening anytime
soon
but joe burrow is a guy that
if if he doesn't have the team around
him that he thinks he should if he
doesn't have the protection that he
thinks he should
and we know how the bengals do their
contracts he's he's a guy that i'm
keeping an eye on as the future unfolds
i hope he stays in cincinnati i hope
he's great in cincinnati um i'm just
keep an eye keep an eye in the coming
years on joe burrow
i actually like that one i think that's
smart i don't think it's going to happen
anytime soon and who knows it probably
never happens but i i think that's uh
that's an interesting one i would say
i don't know if this qualifies in this
category mike but i'm gonna say jimmy
garoppolo
that jimmy garoppolo plays let's give
i'll give you this scenario jimmy
garoppolo plays well this year the
niners go deep into the playoffs
and and garoppolo basically says hey
listen you know you didn't believe in me
a year ago
i want to go now and i think the 49ers
would accommodate him now
under that scenario what would be really
weird i think and you think so too is if
jimmy garoppolo goes 19 for 19 starting
every game this year or however many
games they play
i i think that's probably unlikely but
we'll see
i could see at the end of this year
garoppolo going to john lynch and kyle
shanahan
in an amiable way
and basically saying look it's best for
everybody let me go quarterback the
carolina panthers
hey and you know what it was it will
work out next year if that happens
because no one's touching him at 25
million this year if he plays and plays
the full season and plays well
then you'll have teams that may be
willing to absorb the final year of his
contract in 2022.
i'm staying in the division
and i'm sliding down to arizona and i'm
going to say kyle murray peter i
remember when you made the observation
where murray was drafted this guy's lost
three games in his entire high school
and college football career combined
how's he going to deal with losing at
the next level he's always got the
opportunity to go play baseball he was a
top 10 pick of the oakland a's or las
vegas as the case may be potentially or
portland or some other city but
murray
he's already said hey why shouldn't i be
involved in deciding who we draft i mean
he's he's willing to i think follow the
lead that's been set by others
if that team ends up bottom of the
division this year wrong side of 500 8
and 9 7 and 10 6 and 11 whatever the
case may be i think he's got to keep an
eye on he's getting closer and closer to
the end of his rookie contract i would
watch him
i'm gonna i'm gonna veer away and tell
you a weird name right here okay but i'm
gonna say sam darnold and obviously it's
not what you think
but the way i view sam darnold's
situation in carolina is that he's got a
lot of power in his hands
if he plays really well this year but
david tepper still has his eyes on
desean watson russell wilson you know
some guy in the draft you know sam
darnold could say hey listen you guys
don't believe in me i want out but
that's only if sam darnold plays well
this year and he ends up having a little
bit of the power after the season
yeah it's either one out or get a big
contract that ties them together and
ends this speculation they're gonna make
a move for someone else in cleveland the
constant chatter has been
when are they going to sign baker
mayfield when are they going to sign
baker mayfield well baker mayfield's got
a vote in all of this and baker mayfield
has always been extremely confident in
himself and look i'm not saying he's
looking to leave or he's ever going to
look to leave but he's going to set the
agenda at some point and if they don't
sign him if they don't try to sign him
this year and he has a full season like
the season he had at the end last year
he's going to be holding all the cards
and he's going to drive a hard bargain
and who knows one of these high-end
quarterbacks eventually is going to do
the dak prescott kirk cousins thing and
say i don't want your extension i'll
keep playing year to year and we'll see
how it goes and it can get very
interesting and i can see baker mayfield
having the confidence in himself to do
just that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports